guys it finally happened riot games has
dropped a
massive announcement about the future of
valorant and 2021 is looking crazy
but while they've set themselves up for
success when it comes to esports
infrastructure
you gotta wonder is the game itself
really ready for all this
[Music]
okay before we get into the video proper
i need to direct your attention to that
rectangular red box right below me
if you're not subscribed yet what are
you waiting for
we're on the road to two million subs
last year we hit
one next year i wanna hit two let's make
it happen
alright guys it's official valorent is a
real esport
now unreal okay so this past tuesday
riot games dropped a
huge announcement for what they're
calling the valor champions tour
2021. it details an entire competitive
calendar for next year
structured around three levels of
competition first up there's challenger
level events they're basically regional
local qualifiers
you know hometown hero kind of [ __ ] then
there's masters level events which you
can think of as a kind of regional major
they take place three times a year
and hopefully they won't be regional for
long and then
there's championship level events or i
should say event because there's only
one
it happens at the end of the year and
it's essentially the valorant world
championship
champions will be the apex of the season
a two week long tournament of the top 16
teams from around the world in
attendance and where one team
will be crowned the first valorem world
champion
challenger level events qualify you for
master's level events
masters level events earn you points to
get into the championship event at the
end of the year
it's all very linear common sense stuff
that facilitates story lines now look
don't get me wrong
having dota's ti in the summer is cool
and having two different cs go majors
anchor the two halves of the year
is a unique system i wouldn't want to
change and the league of legends spring
split
is okay it's totally useless point is
riot games is
very good at coloring in the lines
they're very good at
organizing highly structured linear
esports competition
and that's exactly what valor it needs
to
help it graduate to that tier one level
esport
and guys i said help it graduate i
didn't say it was there yet
calm down i mean
honestly guys it's been hard to invest
that much emotional energy and valorent
when all we've had to watch are these
regionalized competitions
for fairly modest prize money that don't
really amount to much and that's clearly
what the valor and champions tour 2021
is meant to address
now we have an entire year of highly
structured
linear meaningful competitive events
that we can follow right up until the
end of the year
and that apex level championship event
this kind of competitive environment is
also very important when it comes to
attracting top flight esports orgs
esports players and
brands if valorent is going to grow and
thrive they need to build a competitive
infrastructure
that means pros can make bank and orgs
can win championships
because listen guys if valorent really
takes off in the next couple of years
okay you have to stop i can't listen to
this anymore i'm sorry
is that demetri's voice i'm hearing yeah
but it's me
look are you really gonna talk about all
these bells and whistles and just
completely ignore the elephant in the
room which is just that
this game kind of sucks okay
dimitri i'll tell you what i'm gonna let
you say your piece but this is still my
video so i'll be back
look everything about riot's
announcement seems great as long as
third-party tournaments are permitted to
run on the side
and the scene is allowed to grow
organically i have zero
issues with their roadmap the problem is
that none of this changes the fact that
in my opinion
and this is just that my opinion
valorent continues to just not be a very
good game
now i know what you're going to say it's
still early there's plenty of time for
riot to turn their cheap counter-strike
clone
into a polished premier product and
you're right
the problem is that in order to do that
they'd need to implement
some very substantial changes and
historically
riot hasn't proven to be the kind of
developer who's into doing that
so what changes am i talking about well
make fun of me
all you want for saying that valorant
has to be like cs go
but please for the love of god give me
some
semblance of a spray pattern the rifling
invalorent is so
random that it feels borderline
skillless stop
fixating on whether the vandal is better
than the phantom
the truth is they both suck the thing is
they have to suck why well because of
the game's
next glaring annoyance movement since
the strafing invalorant is slower and
less
dynamic than in cs the rifles can't be
as crisp
controllable and well usable
because then it would just be super easy
to spray everyone into oblivion although
as
tens was apt to demonstrate
you already can apparently
i'm not kidding running spray is
actually good look at this i can
literally full run with the phantom and
it's pretty accurate
speaking of gun play let's talk about
the op
aside from the general lack of utility
and the sheer existence of jet
the thing that makes the valerian ops
feel so opie
is the fact that everything else is just
so weak
not only do the targets move at a
literally glacial pace
and can't do things like jiggle peak but
their rifles
aren't as precise and abusable as the m4
and ak
then of course there's the maps there
are five maps in this game
and two of them just nobody wants to
play
have fun in a best-of-five final i guess
okay so split has definitely gotten
better since the beta
but icebox dude heco said that he would
literally rather play mirage
than icebox now look i wouldn't go
that far mirage is literally the worst
thing that's ever happened to me
but icebox it is in need of some serious
work if it is ever going to be
competitively viable
and unfortunately when you take all of
this and you throw it together
it makes for a pretty uneventful viewing
experience
now i know not everyone feels this way
and that's totally cool
but i have tried to watch valrant
esports several times
and i just can't it's so
boring everyone's just tiptoeing around
casting overpowered alts
trying not to walk into this wall of
one-dimensional opping
and look i want to be very clear i am
not rooting for valorance to
fail on the contrary i just think that
these criticisms
need to be addressed before we start
treating it like some sort of
tier one cs go killer suffice it to say
if there was a valorem major tomorrow
i wouldn't watch it never mind six
months from now the game
isn't fun to play it's boring as hell to
watch
and if riot were to implement the kinds
of changes that would fix all of that
you'd be left wondering why not just
play cs
okay okay there was some intense
opinions in that
but you make a good point or two the
limited map pool
is really not ideal for the kind of epic
best of five grand final championships
that we're hoping to see from valorant
in 2021 yes the game needs a little work
but i think riot needed to strike when
the iron was hot
this game's entire dna screams esports
and we knew from the start
that riot wanted valorant to be the next
big
thing in fps competition so from riot's
perspective
i think if they sat on valorant and we
got another year of
fairly meaningless regional competition
the whole scene
would be in danger of stagnating there'd
be less interest from
top tier esports orgs there'd be a less
viable career path for
the best esports players and let's be
honest for a second here
there'd be less product for riot to sell
to brands
and at the end of the day that's what
matters to them i kind of think we need
to consider
the valoret champions tour 2021 as the
beta version of valor and esports they
can
tune and fiddle with the game along the
way and maybe in a few years we will
have competition on the level of
league of legends worlds or cs go majors
i also want to just jump back to the
original announcement riot put out and
say maybe the one
less than satisfactory thing was the
fact that
masters level competition is going to be
regionalized and unfortunately
that's down to covid while covid19
continues to
impact international travel masters
events will unfortunately remain limited
to regional competition similar to first
strike
trust us no one is more eager to unlock
international
competition and we're going to continue
to monitor the situation closely for
when we can safely pivot masters events
back to international lands
the other major thing absent in the
announcement were
prize money and tournament organizing
details
now we know that challenger level events
will at least in part be organized by
third parties
and it's a safe bet that the
championship event is going to be
wholly operated by riot but what about
the pastors level events
and on the prize money front when it
comes to the prestige and the hype of an
esports event
cash is king all these are details that
will no doubt be made public in the
coming months but for now it's a very
promising announcement
and honestly i think if you're just a
fan of esports and you've been
missing that high level true competition
in 2020
you got to be happy that riot is going
aggressive on valor and esports in 2021
[Music]
what what is your goal for valor and
ranks colin
uh that's a good question so the last
time
i played ranked and valorent i was in
gold so probably platinum
is my goal um and i honestly think i
could get there it's a lot
easier to play valorent than it is cs go
i think you honestly can't this is not a
knock anyone will tell you this
the thing about valrant is that
everything
plat and lower is trash
in my opinion anyone who plays valor and
who's below diamond is a league player
just by default like i it's just it's
you see it the way they play you see the
way they think the way they talk
there's just something about that truly
low iq brain dead like constitution that
it takes to be a league of legends
player
that's that's what that's what you see
it just transparently scattered
throughout valor and it's one of the
reasons i stopped playing the game
it's terrible ladies and gentlemen it
happened
ladies and gentlemen boys and girls
if you haven't subscribed to thescore
esports yet do it
or do it do it
you